hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and on this video
i'm going to be answering all of your
niggly questions around property
investment so if you've got a property
investment question go ahead comment it
below in the comment box and i'll do my
very best to answer you to help you in
your property investment journey and in
the meantime let's see what questions we
had from last week we've had so many
questions ethan salman says i am a
junior estate agent working at the
start-up business we have loads of
tenants available but barely any
landlords what's the best way
to reach out to landlords let me give
you a little hack ethan there's a
website called open
rent open rent dot co dot uk it's a bit
like right move but it's only for
lettings
and it's only dealing with landlords
direct i'd go on open rent find all
these landlords that are managing their
own properties and then i would just say
to them hey
can we do business and be upfront with
them speak to more people maybe go to
letting agencies
the more people you speak to the more
likely you are to get a deal but there's
so many landlords out there you know
gumtree go on facebook marketplace
and just message and message and message
um good luck i hope it works out
cuba michael
samuel i've saved ten thousand pounds
most
i've ever saved firstly cuba
congratulations really good work ethic
and discipline there how do i get over
the stress
of going through on a deal i've been
finding good deals left right and center
but just can't do it help you know what
um cuba
i feel your pain man i really do and
this is something that is not talked
about enough because
it is stressful
it is when you find your first deal and
it comes to the paperwork and you're
reading over the legals and it's like
insurances and this and that and it's
like oh i can do without this
what i'll say is
everything is hard and everything is
stressful
if you want to be a successful business
person guess what it's going to be
stressful but the stress of success
is better than the success of lack than
the stress of lack of success
i mean being rich comes with problems
and stresses it does but being poor also
comes with problems and i think i just
you know you've got to just accept that
it is going to be stressful and getting
that first deal the confidence the
mindset it is a mountain but if you've
got good deals left right and center and
they're good deals and they're going to
be cash flowing positive then you've
just got to get over your fears and go
ahead and do it but if there's anything
i can do to help you let me know hit me
up on social media i'm rooting for you
brother i really am
film on
i'm currently living in rent in a rented
house
i have a plan
to buy my first home is it better to buy
a residential
or
buy to let thank you
great question philmont there's
advantages and disadvantages to both
idea if you buy a residential house and
it's your first residential house
assuming your credit is good you are
going to be able to get a really high
mortgage which will mean you only have
to put down a small percentage you can
get up to 95
when you're buying a house to live in
which is basically like free money and
the interest is really low you're
talking about two two and a half percent
so
if you are buying and you're a
first-time buyer then of course it's
going to be cheaper you're going to need
less money
however
if you buy a residential house you
cannot rent it out so
you can get consent to rent it out you
could potentially get a lodger in one of
the rooms and pay no tax because you
have seven and a half thousand pounds um
bedroom relief tax um so there are
advantages to buying a residential house
if you're buying a bike to let house
you're gonna put down a bigger deposit
but you're gonna be able to rent it out
and actually make an income from it so
it really just depends on your personal
circumstances there's no better or worse
but i hope that's given you a little bit
of insight and helps you out
reece got seven
rescot 7 says i'm just starting out in
the property game i wanted to deal
source to build some capital to get a
buy to let smart
if you could give me some tips on deal
sourcing or even do a little video that
would be great many thanks loving the
videos bro look forward to more all
right so reese got seven really good
strategy
finding good investments
packaging them
selling them to investors
charging a finder's fee you can get
three four thousand pounds every time
you do that and what's going to happen
is that money you save it you buy your
own property investment and you'll be
able to get a really good property
investment as well you know why because
if you're packaging and selling deals
to make money
you're gonna find a really good deal
you're gonna be like damn this deal's
too good to sell and you're gonna be
able to use the money that you've
saved through deal sourcing good
strategy best piece of advice is
grow your investor list
deal packaging is only possible when you
have investors to sell to so get
networking get trained put yourself
around other people that are doing it so
that it becomes normal and you
understand it and get ready to roll your
freaking sleeves up and get to work well
done my brother if you've got questions
by the way go ahead comment below
audacious abc what's happening all day
just abc what do i say to my bank to
take out equity from a property here's
what you say you say nothing you don't
speak to your bank you're going to speak
to a mortgage broker and the mortgage
broker is not going to speak to your
bank either the mortgage broker is going
to speak to all of the banks and find
you the best right and do all of the
negotiations and conversations for you
and you're going to pay the broker a
small fee which is going to save you and
get you a better interest on your loan
callum coupe
i've noticed you always say
to rent where you live and get a
mortgage on your investment properties
i also agree with this but my girlfriend
wants to own her own house rather than
rent and she believes this is dead money
can you please summarize why we should
rent rather than to buy to try to change
her mindset or outlook on this
your girlfriend is financially [ __ ]
you need to send your girlfriend on some
of my training or make her watch some
youtube videos and if she refuses then
she should become your ex-girlfriend
that's the best piece of advice i can
give you brother um
[Laughter]
why should you rent where you live and
rent out what you own because she thinks
it's dead money to rent
well what's that what about the interest
on on the i tell you what's dead money
the repairs on the house
that doesn't even give you any money if
you buy a house and you live in it every
time a window breaks you gotta pay for
it
out of what money
how are you gonna pay for it see if you
buy a house and rent it out and the
window breaks who's gonna pay for it
your tenants will pay for it not
directly but you're gonna put 10 of the
rent they give you aside for maintenance
it's an asset
you buy a house and rent it out that's
an asset giving you money
so any money that you get you can do
what you want with you can fix up the
property you can buy your own place if
you want if you're [ __ ] or
you can rent where you live
dead money is interest payments dead
money is the deposit that you put down
on a house that doesn't make you any
money
that's dead money rent isn't dead money
you've got to live somewhere
that's like saying bread is dead money
oh i have to buy this food and eat it
it's dead money no
because you're eating it
renting a house isn't dead money because
you're living there
what's dead money is buying a house
and then putting down a deposit
and that house doesn't make you any
money because you can't rent it out
because you're living there unless you
rent out the rooms the only reason you
should buy a house to live in is if it's
so for change money it's like ah you
know what i just want to live in this i
like that house it's an emotional
purchase but i just want it because i
want it and i'm prepared to make that
decision and just see it as sofa change
money but until you become rich rent
where you live
all right next oliver sounder smith he
says can't wait to see you on winners on
a wednesday samuel give me a few years
and i'll be there make that a few months
bro get trained let's do this fast not
get rich quick but get financially
frequent not get rich quick but get
results quick abso freaking lutely l a
massive fan of the channel you've
inspired me to get the ball rolling with
my first property well done i've around
120 000 pounds to invest in my first
adventure
what would you personally do with this
amount of capital if i had 120 grand
what'd i do
i'd buy a rundown house
cash
i'd buy it cheap
why am i going to how am i going to buy
it cheap because i'm buying it cash
if you buy cash you have the i don't
give a [ __ ] mentality right you just go
up to the estate agent i'm buying cash
i'll offer what i want
i'm not messing around with a mortgage
i'm not messing up buying it cash here's
my proof of funds and i'll pay what i
want to pay for it you might cheap
then you fix it up
and then you refinance it and pour your
cash back out now you've got a nice
house giving you cash flow and you've
also got your cash back that's what i
would do with 120 000 pounds right last
one james life
when you do your refurb costs
more than the original quote what do you
do when you do a refurb and it costs
more than the original quote due to
unforeseen circumstances
i don't want unforeseen circumstances
what do you mean my refurbished almost
double
what the original price was due to
structural issues
dude man you need to get a survey on the
house
you you need to get a structural report
you need to get a survey otherwise there
will be unforeseen issues so all i can
say is see it is a big massive l bro
always get a structural survey on a
property if the structural problems you
and you don't know about it
you're killing your business
and that's why i always say you'll
either pay for your mistakes like you
just did or you'll pay for your
education i wish you'd come to my
training first i would have told you
that for 25 pounds well i'm telling
everyone now right now on youtube so if
you enjoy this channel free content man
every single down picking out free
content you want to pay for training you
can pay and i'll mentor you personally
and walk with you or you can just keep
watching videos every day and spitting
out a new video if you appreciate the
content hit the like button if you've
got a question for me hit it in the
comment box below i'll do my best to
help thanks for watching see you next
time my name's samuel peace out